if y'all did a [ __ ] JK competition
you know how many dudes would sign up
dog so many [ __ ] dudes who would you
sign up for first
to get head from in this room yeah oh
man oh wow
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another great
episode of the careful boys today we
have with us Mr Tim hey
[Applause]
yo we haven't seen for a long time dude
that's some [ __ ] enthusiasm people
need to clap for themselves
that's self-love right it's 2023 I'm
sick of being humble dawg
gas me up it will be at some point soon
when the video goes up it might be 2023.
[ __ ] love me want to be humble is
this a new attitude you have no I've
always kind of like sucked my own dick
you know what I'm saying it's kind of
like something else flexible needed to
do I like love to do yeah um I really
believe in being your own cheerleader
and like constant just blind over
confidence in yourself so you really
believe in sucking your own dick you're
gonna take yoga classes so you can reach
I am a firm believer firm good good word
that if everybody was flexible enough we
all would have sucked our own dicks by
now I would have tried it out let me ask
you guys let me ask you guys there's a
lick not to completion yeah yeah let me
ask you because that's gay dude nah is
it gay to suck your own dick no it's a
completion yeah no not even to
completion if you're gonna bust your own
Junior High if I was flexible enough and
you what yeah
let's do 10 second delay what the [ __ ]
of course no no there's a gay way to do
it there's a gay way to do it and then
there's a not gay
if you if you moan at all no you're so
immature has nothing to do with the
moaning is it like a curl in the smile
of your leg no if you're a jacket right
okay and you bust down the middle and
then you go tickle tickle tickle oh just
swallowed my own and then you take it
and then you smear it your mustache or
whatever that's good if you make a mess
out of it but if you're like I gotta I'm
a man you know like [ __ ]
I'm a man and you already did tobacco
you put on the side so you're like
and keep it on the side I'm a man if
that's not gay do you drink it though
you're gonna chew it around no you spit
it out like a man oh you just meant
right now oh [ __ ] you put on to prove
his point put on the side
I ain't gay how do you swallow you have
to say that I ain't gay
that's part of the ritual no no you suck
your own dick you none of your mouth and
you go pause yeah
that's masculine and it's hip-hop but
then we love hip-hop we love it if you
spit into a napkin you're gay again
it's like oh what is that jizz that's
weird you gotta go
maybe even through the nose it's not
Rockets
[Music]
like an old Saloon
you telling me you wouldn't you're
judging me no I'm not judging you I'm
just like so happy that you're an
influencer there's so many men out there
okay how would you want to do it
outside
dude I'm learning I'm taking notes right
now this is it through the nose got it
through the nose
I think that's a gateway drug sucking
your own dick a gateway to what suck
another man's dick oh [ __ ] wow I never
thought of it so he's jacking off
[ __ ] like if we're going to be real
if we're gonna keep it a buck and I know
we all feel this way if here we go I've
never sucked a dick before but like I'll
be good at it because you know what you
like yeah dude I think you gotta be
passionate about it to be good at it
though because if you're sucking it the
whole time you're like
wow enthusiasm goes a long way how do
you like this so that I know you tell me
how you would do it how would you do it
to me and I'll tell you if I like it the
same way wait wait wait wait wait stuck
in my own penis or somebody else's no
more no more questions no more questions
he's basically saying that you already
know what's good so why would you
perform it describe it I'm Bart oh man
that's hard dude because I think I was
talking some [ __ ] Daniel high already
yeah he's hard talking about this [ __ ]
wow whoa you guys called me out and I'm
like I'm a poser and I don't think I've
never gotten any stuck before dude this
is crazy what was the question again how
would you like it and then describe how
you would do it
enthusiasm dude
you just copy what Joe said
wait what a joke I wasn't listening I
was talking about passion enthusiasm we
both can't like the same thing I'm
talking about the technique the physical
yeah start the demo what would you do
would you take the balls would you suck
the dick what would you do how's the
start what's the first thing what's that
I think I think being yeah I think you
have to reach for the balls a little bit
specialist right now dude that was just
like making up what he thinks it is yeah
nobody grab a boob and it feels like a
bag
you know what I mean but yeah I think
all those things you got to be handsy
you got to be touching up here a little
bit dude the [ __ ] I don't want to be
touched on my [ __ ] tits that's what
you that's what I like that's what he
likes yeah we can't argue you like your
breasts cup while you're getting
blowjobed a little bit
sometimes hey sometimes hands on the
cheeks you don't like hands on the
cheeks like this yeah push it on the
butt cheeks okay okay you can push it in
of course not the face cheeks what are
the figures cut there's the figures come
in
just right here it wouldn't be this it'd
be [ __ ] down okay all right have a
quick I have a quick I have a quick
story have a good story because one time
I was [ __ ] like uh I was messing with
this girl and it was this is relates to
your grabbing of the cheeks and I can't
wait so I was sitting on a counter and
while she was giving me a head though
like she was she kept [ __ ] around she
kept grabbing my legs and like
that on the counter that's scary and I'm
[ __ ] cracking up because it felt so
like oh like I felt like a little [ __ ]
right
right then I'll crack it up and she's
like stop squirting like grabbing my
lips like this like yo chill that makes
it worse does that make you squirm more
yeah yeah so I'm like dying but also
like I'm trying to enjoy this [ __ ] oh it
was weird you feel like a little kid
yeah exactly like a kid being put in a
shopping cart with your legs your legs
are dangling oh man I'll pick you up
while suck your dick though I could see
that say what what's your name
when you're really comfortable with
someone so much that you can laugh
during like some freaky times like I I
like that you know what I'm saying that
sounds fun not like [ __ ] on the floor
crying laughing but you know like when
you're like smashing and you hear like a
little [ __ ] and you're in your stomachs
make the fart noise like that shit's
like in both people can laugh yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's wholesome I think yeah
that's true I guess it depends on what
you're laughing at huh yeah that's true
she's like just like laughing at your
dick like haha you're joining it up like
why are you laughing so hard that's
enough it's not that funny like you put
it in she's like
oh no
what about you Anthony Lee what what the
question that bar gave me
do you think we're not out of the woods
[ __ ] grade A deflector over there
dude just throwing it around would you
be good at sucking dick you think
um I've never tried it so I can't claim
I don't want to appropriate the culture
you know you're kind of no but he's good
at a lot of things he does I think he'd
be pretty good uh says the wild zany
Master over there are you are you not a
master dancer a master of movement any
freestyles so that he could catch on I'm
merely a student of the world so I could
learn to suck dick well that's what I'm
saying that's for sure I can learn but I
would have to learn I think with that
attitude you could be one of the greats
I think I'll get ahead of myself you
know I had the choice words
um you know I might be like sticking a
finger in the butt too early you know I
don't know man oh you jumped the gun huh
yeah you know I might get too excited
I'm like I'm trying to perform really
well you know but can I be honest
oh I think I could suck dick better than
I eat [ __ ]
[ __ ] I wish you bro we're on this island
together it's logical because you know
what you like but you don't know how
like what a girl is feeling not just
that but his cheek looks like he got
some Vortex suction power you know what
I'm saying I feel like he could suck the
[ __ ] out of a Tootsie Roll pop that's
true and I know how to tease the dicks
yeah it's all
the guys that go to the gym every every
morning I'm trying to see you dude
that's a hell of a big place no honestly
I really want to know who out there is
down to get your [ __ ] dick sucked by
Bart I'm the only honest one I've never
felt so connected to you ever in my life
dude I was like yeah I agree and you
gotta have like bars blowing up Men's
Health magazine photo shoot all up on
the wall oh the naked one next to that
photo
[Laughter]
yeah I bet you anything I bet you you
know what you know what I woke up
thinking about guys
I didn't lose that bet by the way did
someone go no I think you said you
definitely [ __ ] better
I think I think I'd be a horrible
[ __ ] [ __ ] really I think the
key to [ __ ] Sucking is I know the I know
where it might feel good but the key is
commitment like you gotta go all in or
else I'm gonna be like a lazy mouth
[ __ ] I'll just be like you know what
just about it I'll just be like just
[ __ ] my mouth
you know and then like you know what's
funny is like it's interesting to hear
everyone's a different take on it you
know like you'd be just a hole for
something because I can't be grossed out
the whole time I can't be like
they're like all [ __ ] give me a
[ __ ] break dude is that is it that
bad and I'm all like yeah it's kind of
bad do you have a strong uh gag reflex
so you have an assumption that he's not
testing the dick then huh you you're
basically assuming that only you would
have a dick in hand like I don't want to
do this where's Bob would be like yes my
part's committed though that's the
difference he could he could be like you
know this is gross but I [ __ ] came to
do a job yeah yeah and then for me I'll
be complaining the whole time like why
is it gonna be so big and [ __ ]
I can't it in my mouth if it's on Bart's
calendar it's gonna get done
he's like [ __ ] sucking Friday night
he's like JK news commenters all right
sort the recycling suck a dick
floss good night collect on the back
what if there was a competition what if
it was like five dudes whoever makes the
person come the fastest is like oh JK
party episode bring it back way better
than Mafia to pay us 10 million dollars
how about we need willing dicks first oh
that won't be hard willing dick come on
you guys are such [ __ ] you know how
many like I don't give it that we have a
lot of like even straight guys that
would want to [ __ ] us so if y'all did a
dick sucking JK competition you know how
many dudes would sign up dog so many
[ __ ] dudes who would you sign up for
first
if if I had to choose someone to get
head from in this room yeah no man oh
wow oh that's a big honor honest hey
honest answers only dude for real you
gotta think about this [ __ ] honest
answers only I mean honestly hold on
hold on before you make your your pick
we can make it easier it's a glory hole
picture of chia on one side no no not a
picture of us no this is about y'all
picture of our group this is about y'all
let's make it real she is on one side
and it's just a picture of us
you should know let's make it real
watching me in shame and then it's just
me staring at all y'all and so but so I
feel like the the situation is that all
you guys are down to suck the dick all
of us are down here
he's honestly down I'll [ __ ] commit
whatever you think it's yeah we're just
we're gonna do it regardless of being
down we're gonna get this money honestly
I feel like sit down to y'all what
because they're the prettiest ones hey
got nice hair you can hold look at this
little hair
his waves are natural I got nice hair
you can hold it dude Anthony and Ryan
are the prettiest for sure what's your
first move turn on o by Omarion see
that's already wrong peace
what's our first move Ryan you know
what's funny I don't think I'll be good
at it
my jaw has this thing where like it
locks it clicks open at a point I'm not
big my guy yeah wait a quick open you
mean like a like a snake yeah yeah look
look to get all the way open look
like this
oh wait that might feel kind of crazy
you might win you just got another one
pair I might win
this guy gets to pull out parties first
I got nothing impressive because that's
like the popper you know like when you
think he dances and then I'll think
about his elbow yeah he's double jointed
pop lock on the dick under the shoulder
sucking version of that yeah you're like
okay I think you want it's the dick
sucking version of bad guys Ryan always
wins man I don't think it's good so I
think I'll get second place you think
that's it
dude it's gonna work trust me I'll tell
you what I'll do you have a mix Tim is
going to stay right here like this right
it doesn't have no pants on the first
thing I do is I start from up here why
are you angry I scratch I use my
fingernails I slowly and then I spread
his knees
hey man
um I like I like this picture you're
painting dog see yeah and then I'll do
that
[Laughter]
keep it
we need you here to confirm
feels like that's not a hard fact
the first video of the day it's eight in
the morning it is crazy oh my God what
ads are gonna be on this video she was
like this is what do we title this
[ __ ] better help
this is a wild rocket Blue Apron
freshly fresh damn oh well [ __ ] I'm not
gonna argue yeah oh my God yeah I think
Bart won yeah I'm not mad at that I'd
say part one I think you're the throat
goat
I don't like that name though why not
all right let's just come first place
[Laughter]
throat goat took the
took the first place
this part is the throat hashtag throat
go dude that's pretty tight does it does
it make me gay that I don't like deep
throating
people getting deep throated yeah um
what don't you like about it no because
why am I confused I see so much porn and
I feel like I should be enjoying it
because everyone seems to like it and
I'm like I don't like deep throating
that much I understand what you're
saying I think it it all comes down to
individuals and like and your unique
situations because okay so I curved to
the right I say this in a lot of videos
um and it was only probably like I like
deep thoughting was whatever to me until
this one girl who knew to get on the
right side of me so that it like
seamlessly went like and treated her
throat when I was like oh [ __ ] this is
I've never felt this before wow because
like when other girls would try to
[ __ ] me straight like straight
forward it just never was like hitting
right you know what I'm saying never
lining up correctly and this girl's like
oh oh oh oh okay I understand she knows
how to do the captcha she did this knows
how to put the [ __ ] star in the star
line that [ __ ] sidewalk dude
[Laughter]
she grabbed his butt cheeks
what a breakthrough all of you guys have
no curves
the straight is narrowed it I I hang
left okay that's disgusting yuck when
you say that it's like like this yeah or
like this yeah yeah like so it's not
like this
like when I'm like like fully erect it's
like a pretty like substantial like like
that situation so it's like this way
yeah yeah oh cool I thought it just only
went like that or like that
mine's to the right yeah it's an Asian
back stretcher yeah so it it probably
works when you're doing like a um like a
sideways yes but it's like like the
sideways sex is nice so what I would not
one of my like moves like this way it
was like uh me signature
on like on on her left side the [ __ ]
goes up and in wow that's cheating
yeah that's how you make it work
oh if it goes like this okay this way
right then you move it like this and
then you put it in G-spot yeah exactly
exactly and you have to say that out
loud
imagine
and she goes oh
yeah
yeah
oh my God he's Jason Bourne everyone's
hyped dude everyone's having a good time
that's kind of an advantage I wonder if
you can get a curve put in oh god oh
like a like a like a stint pretty nice
yeah or you can train for it yeah yeah
you could probably train for it you can
yeah dude you gotta get one of those
pipe cleaners you put it in and then you
bend it after it oh
like it's like feet binding but it's
called Dick curving yeah it's on the
inside out man it's ancient Chinese
tradition yeah they're good at that
stuff making the stallion has a whole
song like devoted to guys with curved
dicks really yeah it's called Captain
Hook yeah is that really what that's
talking about she's so inclusive can we
start can we start calling you Captain
Hook sometimes if you like okay cool
because we're gonna leave it on the
table we'll see we'll see that's better
Captain Hook is better go for sure his
signature move is way cooler than yours
[Music]
laughs